sa tournée entamée en février s'est
poursuivie hier soir aux francofolies de
la rochelle
vingt ans après la séparation du groupe
téléphone jean-louis aubert est toujours
aussi populaire
témoin ce concert hier véritable moment
de communion avec le public
michel vial et georges d'une angoisse
je suis
entre rock et folk jean louis aubert
hier soir aux francofolies réussissait
une fois de plus le mariage parfait du
rythme et de la balade un mélange
d'énergie et d'émotion qu'il traduit
avec la pugnacité des grands timides
tous les artistes et chanteurs se
rencontrer
beaucoup de timidité
ils sont avides de monter sur scène
parce que parce qu'ils ont été timides
soit dans leur enfance oublie continue à
l'être et hélas il
il s'invente à un autre même
non
joie
arrivé tard à la rochelle l'artiste n'a
effectué ni balance ni répétition mais
l'exercice auquel ils s'apprêtaient
constitue un vrai cadeau pour nous
à la distance
la révolte adolescente des années
téléphone à la maturité sereine
aujourd'hui jean louis aubert est resté
lui même grâce à cette voix particulière
qui porte de sa jeunesse irréductibles
d'ailleurs évidemment il ya le ce rêve
adolescents de devenir un chanteur de
monter sur scène aussi
on endort du plaisir de l'art la
camaraderie de guérir mais mes blessures
de quelques fois accompagné aussi mémé
tristesse ce que doit faire la musique
j'ai l'impression qu'elle a 6 à 10
en mettant en avant sa voix il a appris
à accepter sa présence attachante
jean louis aubert écrit et chante ses
espérances il n'a rien perdu des idéaux
qui l'ont propulsé sur scène et qui ont
gardé intact son âme d'enfant
sur scène
les blessures sous pavillon